what really happened to make thor and
jane break up and why is their
relationship been such a mystery until
now luckily thor love and thunder
provides some much needed answers
the fourth installment in the chris
hemsworth-led franchise sees a highly
anticipated return of natalie portman as
dr jane foster despite having such a
prominent presence in phase one and two
of the marvel cinematic universe she's
been mysteriously missing since then
compared to other couples in the marvel
universe thor and jane haven't been
given that much attention at least when
compared to the likes of tony stark and
pepper puts however jane's
transformation into the mighty thor
forces a reunion that's eight years in
the making it's a good thing that thor's
been doing some self-reflection because
he has to face off against gore the god
butcher played by christian bale as well
as deal with some unresolved emotions
about his now superpowered ex-girlfriend
the pair is certainly on rocky ground
after such a long time apart but even
valkyrie portrayed by tessa thompson can
tell they still have feelings for one
another the narrative dives deeper into
the duo's romance expanding on what
viewers know about their short time
together most importantly the film
finally answers the question of what led
to jane and thor's breakup which thor
previously alluded to in thor ragnarok a
series of flashbacks said to abbas our
last summer and narrated by taiko iti's
cork show us exactly what happened
i believe that fate
brought us
together thor and jane's love story
begins like so many that have come
before it with jane hitting the god of
thunder with her van in the desert it
didn't take long for jane and her
friends to become advantageous allies to
thor in his fight against his brother
loki played by tom hiddleston along the
way thor learns how to be truly worthy
to wield mjolnir and through all this he
and jane fall in love their next
potentially world-ending adventure comes
in thor the dark world when jane absorbs
aether once again it's up to thor to
ensure his girlfriend remains safe and
that's the last time we really see them
together thor love and thunder fills in
some blanks but between the two films
the audience doesn't see the two
interact at all this is certainly
strange in the context of avengers age
of ultron when thor attends a party at
avengers tower and jane is nowhere to be
found so i'm not even sure what country
jane's in
he just practiced compatriots about
jane's accomplishments in the scientific
field but why wouldn't he invite her to
a big party surely she would have liked
to have met tony stark and steve rogers
of course it's possible that this
fictional couple was still together but
on shaky standing at that point in thor
ragnarok thor definitively states that
he and jane have broken up but until now
we had no idea what actually transpired
between the two thor love and thunder
takes fans behind the scenes of thor and
jane's relationship in fact the film
reveals that the pair even lived
together for a while enjoying each
other's company while making breakfast
and snuggling up on the couch to watch
movies everything was apparently going
great for a while but thor soon became
overwhelmed by his fear of losing jane
even though he could envision a future
with her thor was scared of the hardship
his world-saving activities could bring
after all his enemies targeted jane and
thaw the dark world and they could again
thor let his negative thinking get the
better of him and it drove a wedge
between the couple to distract himself
from his relationship woes the god of
thunder frequently went off world on
missions and jane began spending more
time at work attention in the couple's
relationship eventually reached a
boiling point sadly indifference and
resentment built until thor and jane
found themselves constantly bickering it
was jane who pulled the plug on their
romance although thor claimed that their
split was more of a mutual dumbbank
although this is somewhat hard to
believe despite their history the pair
is still drawn to one another even
though their dramatic parting clearly
still has an effect on both of them thor
hasn't been truly vulnerable with anyone
in years and jane is falling victim to
workaholic tendencies despite her cancer
diagnosis in the end their
reconciliation allows both characters to
finally move on
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you